microsoft is a pure example
of absolute tyranny the decisions are
made at the top
they're handed down to the next level at
the very
bottom you have the right to rent
yourself to them
as soon as you start deregulating it
moves towards monopolization
that's the result of handing things over
to the market
that's the result of politicians being
for sale but to sit here and say
everything is the private's fault and
everything good that ever happened was
because of the public and the government
that's
extremely naive to say that classical
liberals would have despised
subordinating yourself to a master and
mostly your waking life
that's the form of state capitalism that
we have and i think we should move
towards a system in
which the classical labor ideals are
realized
that's what your interpretation is so
you you continue to take the extremely
naive i think you're thinking i use your
word
of talking about the individuals what
the public created
is it impossible for you to break out of
this
looking naively and refusing to look at
the institutions in which they function
so everybody in the world has heard of
mit right i mean think about when
somebody goes to mitch oh my gosh she
graduated from mit but think about it if
somebody
talked at mit for 60 years
that's what my guest did today mr noam
chomsky
who also has written over 150 books
he's a famed american linguist some call
him
the father father of modern linguist
he's a philosopher cognitive scientist
historian social critic
political activist and with that being
said professor noam
thank you so much for being a guest on
valuetainment
glad to be with you so i got a lot of
different nodes and i'm trying to see
what angle to take with you but i'll get
right into it if you don't mind taking a
moment
and for the few viewers that maybe don't
know you
there's a lot of interesting ways people
describe you you're described as the
uh uh uh you know aligning with
anarcho-syndicalism and libertarian
socialism can you just give us an idea
about what some of your beliefs
philosophically politically
and economically are there was
classical liberalism came to grief
because it was undermined by the rise of
capitalism
but the basic ideas
of classical liberalism namely that
people should be
not subjected to the domination of
masters should be
free to determine their own fate should
he work together an association to
make a better world all of this remained
but
outside the framework of mainstream
ideology
and libertarian socialism is the
standard term in europe for
what is here sometimes called national
national
and arc anarchism uh which try to
realize the ideas of the enlightenment
and classical liberalism are basically
the
idea that authority
and domination are not self-justifying
they have to justify themselves and if
they can't
which is usually the case they should be
dismantled
in terms of more free and participatory
societies so the great
19th century uh
theorist of classical liberalism uh john
stuart mill
told that in industry
and the economy generally the natural
form to which a civilized society should
develop is self-management
by associations of workers in production
by people in community and so on
without any arbitrary hegemonic
authority
got it so you know almost all of us
who create our own set of beliefs
whether it's spiritual
political philosophical economical
there's somebody that influenced us
whether it's
hey i read von mises oh my gosh great
stuff i'm a capitalist
i read ein rand i totally get by i'm
more like a libertarian or i read karl
marx guy's got some good arguments when
you think about what's being done you
know i read
who were some of the folks that
influenced you the most
actually the people who influenced me
the most
are people whose names will never be
known
people on the front lines of the
struggles for justice and for freedom
uh take say the american civil rights
movement
uh if you ask about the civil rights
the name that comes to mind is martin
luther king
who was a great figure i they respect
him
but he would have been the first to tell
you that he was riding on a
groundswell that was prepared by others
by young snake workers
whose names you don't know who were
riding freedom buses
in alabama to try to encourage
black farmers to dare to go to vote
in the face of lynch mobs and
brutal sheriffs and so on many of them
suffered
some were killed those are the kind of
people who
i think we should respect and honor we
rarely even know their names and there
are people like that
all over the world much of what they do
is very inspiring
i can't find any higher inspiration than
that
what books maybe and that was very
helpful to should i because it makes me
think but
what books what books did you read as a
young man coming up because it seems
like
a lot of your philosophy was established
very early on and i know
you you know in one of your books you
talk about how you grew up as a center
leftist more on like the fdr political
type of a a range where you were with
your family
but what books were they when you read
and you said
this just makes a lot of sense why
aren't people understanding this were
there any books that impacted you
so many that i can't list them
but uh ranging across the spectrum
so ranging from when i was a young
teenager
from uh russell's bertrand russell's
history of philosophy
to pamphlets by
uneducated workers without
people with peasants without formal
education
in spain during the
anarchist revolution who recorded what
they were doing
to collectivize their own villages and
take control of their lives
things that i was picking up in
anarchist bookstores
in 4th avenue uh
new york where it used to go as a young
teenager
so a whole range of things got it
who were you in high school if you and i
were 16 years old in high school
together i'm sitting next to you i go to
school with you for two years
who would have people said who gnome was
at 16 17 years old
in high school in high school who were
you in high school
high school i was sort of a loner
had a couple of friends some of them
remained friends till
the end of their lives just a couple of
years ago
but not many mostly i kept to myself and
i was involved in
lots of intensive political activities
of a in a different area most of my own
engagements direct engagements in the
time
had to do with uh
with what was then the zionist movement
now it would be called anti-zionist
and this is before the state of israel
was formed it's the
we're talking about the early 40s and i
was involved with groups
that were working towards
developing a a bi-national
arab jewish cooperative community
based on working-class cooperation
between
palestinian and jewish workers
that ideal bits and pieces of it were
realized but
most of it changed radically in 1948
but that was the main activities i was
in and
in many ways still am that's lasted
through my life
and among if you ask about influences
a lot of the people who influenced me
were people writing in
at that time in hebrew people like
great essayist
who was committed to a form of what he
called cultural zionism
a zionist recreation of a
cultural center in palestine
which would reinvigorate jewish culture
for the entire diaspora
and who wrote eloquently in fact
that the incoming settlers
will have to pay attention to the fact i
can't ignore the fact
that this country is settled settled by
palestinians
we're going to live with them we're
going to deal with them on an
equal basis we have to be integrated
with them into the world that we're
creating
that that's the turn of the century
in 1900 so you've been a true believer
for a very very long time
a true believer very long time in your
philosophy can you can you remember
when it was when your philosophies were
core to the point where nobody could
change your mind on certain set of
philosophies that you had
i've never reached that point but we
should always be open-minded
willing to listen to new ideas and
arguments
right so my own i wouldn't even call it
a philosophy
my own general points of view about
the nature of life were formed as early
as i can remember
uh early child i grew up in the
depression
so there was really deep poverty uh
my own family elsewhere and those scenes
stay with me miserable
people coming to the door trying to sell
rags
something like that these are
these are indelible memories and i've
now seen it all over the world
that's the kind of place i gravitate to
whether it's in southern colombia or
eastern turkey or refugee camps in
lebanon
or many other places where it's gone
or right here in the united states you
don't have to go very far to see it
most of the world has only seen that in
movies you know you you watch the movies
and you the only way you can get a
depiction of what happened in the great
depression
let me go watch a movie and maybe i'll
get an idea of it i mean i was
born and raised in iran and i lived
there for 10 years and the war happened
between iran and iraq i remembered
clearly
and going to germany living at a refugee
camp for a couple years and seeing what
that was like a small little camp we had
and then finally coming to the states
so living in iran i grew up
watching folks going across the street
protesting flagellating their backs with
a streak of blood on the ground
screaming out death upon america i
witnessed that as a kid for 10 years
obviously not from the day i was born
say from four years old five years old
earliest memories
you would see that and as a kid that
kind of leaves a mark kind of like what
you saw on the great depression side
but there was also another community
that loved america and wanted to come to
america
for the freedoms it offered everybody i
think has a different definition of what
america means to them
what does america mean to you it means
many different things
ranging from some of the worst crimes in
human history
like the most vicious system of slavery
that was ever created which still
its legacy is very much with it
including the
virtual extermination of the indigenous
population
uh at one extreme at the other extreme
breaking new barriers in
popular democracy
developing the concept of we the people
which was a
revolutionary concept in the 18th
century
moving on to protecting
freedom of speech to a degree that's
unknown elsewhere
so a mixture of extreme horrors
and subs exciting achievements
which which achievements to you would
you say
are some of the best achievements
americans had as a nation
the pioneering from the 18th century
of mass public democracy
it's been a struggle all the way the
founding fathers were strongly opposed
to it
the constitution as a
aristocratic doctrine which seeks to
marginalize the general public
but then come constant struggles
constant
all through the years that try to
provide some real meaning
to the concept we the people when i
talked about
snake workers in alabama that's one kind
of contribution
when you talk about
young people from the sunrise movement
occupying congressional offices today
to try to get conkers to move towards
taking steps that will save the human
species from
self-destruction that's another kind of
step
so you see these things all the way
through history
if you like it's a kind of it's kind of
sharp class war being fought constantly
and you have both sides it's not
contradictions they're
opposing forces and that's the course of
history
so you can see horrors
iran is a case in point
you can take a look at
the memoirs of general robert heuser
who was dispatched by president carter
to carry out a military coup in
iran in 1979
you can see the blurb by
zbigniew brzezinski carter's national
security adviser who says yes
then this vindicates him if uh
a military coup had been carried out
maybe
killing who knows how many people uh
uh we could have maintained the rule of
the shah
the u.s imposed in 1953
overthrowing iran's parliamentary
democracy
so you can see that you can see other
things
yeah i mean that that that was so you
you were not supportive of what carter
did to not help
the shah at a time where they kept
saying it's going to be all right it's
going to be all right it's going to be
all right and then obviously there was a
follow the shot you supported
the shah meaning you would have liked it
to stay the way it was
that's a different question once he was
ousted
the question is how should he be treated
i felt despite his enormous crimes and
they were terrible
he should be treated humanely but that's
a separate question from
carter brzezinski plan to carry out a
military coup actually this was
described
openly by uh israel's
de facto ambassador to iran
who publicly announced and said 1979
that
israel had very close relations with
isha that
what's needed in iran as a bloody
military coup which may kill 10 000
people
but that will suppress the uprising and
restore the
tyrannical rule of the shop that's what
they had in mind
well i'm opposed to that but i'm in
favor of treating the tyrant
humanely once he was ousted interesting
i mean if you
study it a little bit deeper i'm from
there so i put a little bit more time
into that specific topic
was also the 25-year contract the oil
between france germany uk and i'm sure
you were this with us
where they were not happy about the fact
that the shot was about to raise the
prices in 1979 was a specific year when
the prices was going to go up
so they had a private meeting in south
or central america to figure out a way
to make the
this strategy was four nations wanting
to make sure he didn't stay in power the
way he did so
it was extremely strategic but it's
interesting to see the fact that you
still want
the individual to be treated in a humane
way you know if i if i read some of your
books like if i read who rules the world
the book that you wrote
uh who rules the world uh if i watch
your documentary if i watch some of our
interviews if i go watch you
and william buckley have a debate
if i go watch any of the stuff that
you've done a lot of work your catalog
of work is very wide
and very deep i don't get the most
positive feeling about america almost if
i had someone who was not
an individual who had spent a lot of
time wanting to study
uh the history of america say i have 50
students here and i have 50 students
here neither one of them have ever
studied the history of america if i gave
him your material to read
and study for a year i'm willing to bet
most of them after you
after you would probably hate america
you know a lot of the
things that i read it doesn't come
across as there is that
that love of what a great country
america is for you and you make a lot of
good arguments in your books i'm
watching to see what your points are on
this okay this makes sense i see where
he's going with this
do you still maybe it's not even still
do you think america has
or is ever been the greatest country in
the world
there's no such concept as the greatest
country in the world
just as there is no greatest human being
in the world
countries have many complex
characteristics
some of them very outstanding
wonderful others hideous so
take some other country let's take
germany
uh some of the greatest thinkers
scientists
artists in the world the depths of human
history
as well what's more it flips quickly
from one to the other
you just can't make comments like that
i'm in his journey
in the 1920s germany was regarded as the
peak
of european civilization and the
sciences philosophy
the arts was regarded as a model of
democracy
the 1930s ten years later was regarded
as the depths of human history
ten years later beginning of a return
to what it once was so what's germany
what's england england has an absolutely
hideous record of atrocities and
destruction
for centuries iran in fact is a case in
point
i know a lot about it but
iran could have moved in the early 20th
century
towards democracy and freedom the
british
crushed it when iran tried to
take control of its own energy resources
in the early 50s
britain tried to crush it by force
when they were unable to they asked the
big guy across the atlantic to come in
and smash it for them
okay that's one side of britain not the
worst by any means
on the other side it has again
my favorite philosophers in history
right in front of me i have a book
about the friendship between adam smith
and david hume in the 18th century
two outstanding figures to
my famous figures in history so that's
another side of england
so what's your attitude towards england
you can't answer
just too many things same with every
other place you can think of
so i don't see any except for people at
patriotic rallies
i don't think you should ask questions
like uh
what's the greatest country so would you
would you be able to say
you know you 60 years you've given to
mit most of your life you've lived in
america you've been all over the world
would you be able to say i love my
country america
i don't love countries love
is a relationship between people
when you love countries there's
something wrong
should you have loved uh germany
when it was carrying out the holocaust
uh should you have lived germany when it
was at the peak of human civilization
you care for people and the societies in
which they live
i care for many societies including this
one
but you don't love countries
i don't think you should i think there's
an emotional connection sometime with
certain set of values
that one nation offers to you where the
other one where you grew up and didn't
it's almost like a
i'm not i'm i wasn't born here i'm not a
us citizen i can never run to be the
president here or maybe i can do
governor or something like that but this
is not really where i was born
but this country welcomed me with open
arms and gave me an incredible life
and uh to compare to where i was raised
at i mean
you know the worst day in america is
still 10 times better than the best day
in iran so that's what i mean where
maybe for you you had some kind of a
love for the country that you know gave
you the opportunity to become
the country sorry the country didn't
give you the opportunity
certain people within the country
gave you the opportunity while
preventing
others victims of their own crimes
from having that opportunity they gave
you the opportunity
because you were a refugee from a
country that was an official enemy
okay that's what they did
take me my parents fled
from eastern europe uh
horrible conditions and did manage to
get to the united states
uh and they managed to
create a good life for themselves an
even better one for me
okay on the other hand a couple of years
after they fled from europe
they happened to make it just before the
first world war
a few years later in 1924
the united states passed a law
immigration law of 1924 which was aimed
particularly at jews and italians
some jewish the idea was to keep
jews and italians away from the country
because they were
not up there we don't want that kind of
rabble around
well that helped put most of my extended
family
into the gas chambers okay
they couldn't come here because they
were bored in the
1930s they can refuge
jewish refugees continued to be bored or
virtually a few were let in
in the late 40s when they were still in
concentration camps
but then desperately trying to get out
the united states wouldn't have a
central americans who were
victims of massive u.s atrocities
were being kept out right at this moment
they're being driven away from the
border when they flee from
refuge from horrors that we created from
the 80s
okay so it's a very mixed story sure i'm
glad to have been able to come to the
richest country in the world with
advantages that don't exist anywhere
else
thanks to the extermination and
expulsion of the native population
so yes for me that's very good does that
mean i
love the country no i admire some things
within
it i think we should despise other
things within it
and the same is true of every other
country would you call yourself a
pessimist or a
optimist well i when asked that i always
appeal to the
slogan that antonio gramsci
made famous we should have
pessimism of the intellect and optimism
of the will
a lot of things that are wrong that's
what you should concentrate on
trying to make them better and we should
be optimistic about the power to do so
no matter what the obstacles yeah it
almost reminds me of uh
you you studied obviously a lot of
philosophy i'm assuming you also studied
probably stoicism with seneca and
you know marcus aurelius and and the
whole how
stoicism got started where prior to it
used to be called cynicism and couple
guys are like listen
i don't want to be part of this cynicism
community
it was a philosophy and you know seneca
kind of stepped away and says i'm just
going to go do something else and then
boom stoicism got started
uh into what it is today but it was
it was more of the mindset of i can do
something about my life to improve my
life do you believe the
individual has the ability
and the control and the responsibility
and the ultimate level of accountability
to help
improve their situation and their lives
not just your own life
but to improve the world for all of them
and those are right now
the most urgent questions that have
ever faced the human species
after all we might not like to think
about it
but we have about a decade or two
to answer the question as to whether
organized human life will persist on
earth
nothing less than that very stark
question how certain are you of that to
say a decade or two that's a pretty
extreme
statement to say we only have a decade
or two why do i say that
yes it's a fact if we don't if we don't
deal with the increase
of heating the environment
we will reach tipping points which are
irreversible doesn't mean everybody's
going to die tomorrow but we'll be off
on a course
which will be unstoppable and will lead
to
essentially the end of organized human
life on earth
along with millions of other species
which we're destroying at the same time
i can't be certain about this but
there's a very
high probability of it in fact virtual
unanimity among scientists that this is
what's going to happen
unless we take control within the next
few decades
so to say it's a fact that's that's a
pretty strong uh
statement to say it's a fact fact means
like
you know a hundred percent we're going
to be there and
nothing is a hundred percent okay
quantum theory is not 100
theory of relativity is not a hundred
percent in the empirical world
you never have certainty you own i'm
just saying you said fact i'm just
repeating you said facts i think what
you're saying
there's a possibility but not
necessarily factual yes
there's a background understanding since
the 17th century
that in the world of empirical fact
you never reach certainty so when we
talk about facts as we do freely
we always mean it with that
qualification in the background
we're not going to stop using the word
fact
like it's a fact that
if i take this coffee cup and i let go
of it
it's a fact that it'll fall to the
ground so there in fact is a very slight
possibility
that it'll rise to the sky okay happens
to be the case
things there's a spectrum of
possibilities of which the
overwhelmingly high probability
so high that there's no need in the
practical world to consider
anything else is it'll fall to the
ground but there does
happen to be a very miniscule
possibility that it might go to the sky
but when we talk about facts we have
that understanding in the background
yeah i mean i just never seen anything
fall out and i've lived 42 years i've
had a hard time seeing i mean if things
would have gone up and i would have
jumped a little higher i would have been
in the nba today so i'm hoping that was
kind of favoring me but i couldn't jump
more than 15 inches so
i could never go into the nba so
factually some of this stuff maybe i got
some work
done actually there is not that you
would do it but it's just one of the
things that could happen in the universe
so yeah it could happen in the universe
but that's a good that's not a fact
though that's a
but to say factually in the next 10 or
20 years that makes somebody sit there
and say
two times two is four that's a fact two
times two is not going to be five
tomorrow there's a possibility to be
five tomorrow
that that puts a lot of fear in some
folks who haven't who haven't read as
much as you have to say
to say the world you know we're going in
the direction with climate change in 10
or 20 years that's a scary thought
no sorry that's a misunderstanding so
every
empirical fact that you can think of
has a possibility of being wrong
whatever it is that's been understood
for centuries
that's different that's that could be
your opinion my opinion
research who wrote it it's not a matter
of opinion
by now modern physics even explains it
in some detail
so it doesn't mean we should stop
talking about facts of course we should
but we should talk about facts with a
recognition
always barely possible sometimes almost
inconceivably small probability that
they're wrong
so we continue to talk about facts so
when i say
it's a fact that this is going to happen
that means there's an overwhelmingly
high probability
and we know the reason i think there's a
big number of the factors and so on
if you want every statement that's ever
made
to be added to this qualification okay
i don't think that's a wise policy we
should continue to talk about facts sure
no i i just think you know one of the
reasons why
we've gotten to where we are in america
this is my opinion this is not a fact
this is my opinion i'm very comfortable
being wrong
i think one of the reasons why we've
gone to where we are today in america as
divisive as we are is because both
sides think everything they believe in
is 100 factual
you know this is coming from a skeptical
christian this is coming from a guy that
grew up an atheist for 25 years
and i'm sitting there debating all these
different issues in the bible i'm like
wait a minute this doesn't mean
i'm a math guy so i understand what
you're saying i appreciate that but
let's go to a different topic here
so let's talk about capitalism let's
talk about capitalism we have different
economical systems in the world
you know no matter how much i study what
you say
you'll take shots at obama then you'll
take shots at bush
then you'll take shots at nixon then
you'll take shots at carter
then you'll take shots at trump so it's
not like you are
blindly no matter what only defending
anybody that
is on one side you're not that that's
not you you're not a
uh a such and such person such a perfect
leader he can never make a mistake
you don't come from that gives you a lot
of credibility as a reader to say i'm
actually interested to see what he's
thinking about it
here but if we look at economical
systems we've got capitalism we've got
socialism we've got communism
and then you know a couple other things
a marxism would be pretty much the same
as socialism communism
a part of it what what do you think
about like when you when you think about
capitalism out of all the systems that
we've had
and the results that capitalism has
created what are your thoughts on
capitalism
well first of all i have a different
conception of the
various options in the world you see
many different kinds i see
one every society
that's functioning has some variety of
state capitalism
uh some elements of capitalism
constrained by state power that's true
the united states
it's true of britain it was true of
russia under the
so-called communists that's true of
china
we can look at the different variants of
state capitalism that exist
i think they all have some advantages
many defects now as far as
this my discussing biden
obama bush and so on uh
there are two kinds of we have a certain
we have a finite amount of time and
energy
we can decide how to use it one way to
use it
is to march in parades praising
the magnificence of our leaders and uh
countries along with great mass of other
people
pretty useless activity in my opinion
the
other the other possibility is to see
what's
wrong with existing societies and work
to try to change them
my feeling is that's where attention
and energy it should be devoted
so every one of those figures that you
mentioned
did a lot of things that i think were
very wrong very harmful
to others and ourselves and i think
not just them but the people around them
the social forces that
within which they were functioning and
so on so i think the sensible thing to
do is look at those and try to improve
and change them
if that gives an impression of being
negative
yes it's true i think we should be
negative about things that ought to be
changed
if you want to applaud join the
multitudes and the parades and
praise what's nice fine that's okay it's
not a
very worthwhile you want to do it on
july 4th okay
but not devoting your life to it so
so we should emphasize on the wrong work
that you do
you're saying so as a reader you've
written 150 books so rather than looking
at ideas you have in your book that
makes sense i as the reader should look
at the things that's wrong about you
not the things you write that's right
about you so that's kind of what you're
suggesting
if you're if you have some special
interest in me
say you're my mother then
you should be interested in the things
that i do that i shouldn't be doing
okay if you care about me
if not but if not i gotta constantly be
looking so if you care about the u.s
if you care about u.s society if you
don't care about u.s society
just go marching a parade if you do care
about u.s society
you'll take a look at what you think
ought to be changed and improved
so so what you're saying is if i'm
constantly looking at things that are
wrong
instead of things that are right i
should you that that to me means
less celebration more being critical so
i should spend more time protesting than
attending parades
not just protesting trying to change
if you care about the society at all
you'll be concerned with trying to
change
the things that are wrong that hamper
its development
that hurt the people in it and that are
harming other people in the world
you'll be committed to changing those if
you care about the society
if you don't care about the society at
all you can march in periods
yeah but you know the the i mean i get
that okay fine let's let's continue with
that so capitalism what
what is in your opinion what is wrong
with capitalism where do you see the
flaws and challenges and capitalism of
what will be a better alternative
than capitalism well first of all since
there is no capitalism
almost everything we have is an
alternative to it everything
in faith if there were capitalism
it would probably self-destruct within
no time
that's why the business world pretty
much in charge
has always invariably called upon state
power to protect them from the
ravages of the market and to subsidize
them
and to carry them through the next stage
to develop the next stage of the economy
and so on
uh why let's be quite concrete
we're now using computers the internet
satellites uh microelectronics so on
where'd all that come from mostly from
public investment uh you got a vacancy
from public investment you mean the gut
so so most of the innovation we've had
in america came from the government not
from the people
that's what you're saying of course i
mean i was at mit in the 50s and 60s
when
most of this was being developed it was
being developed on public funds
so so that's a that's that's that could
be an opinion that could not be
necessarily
a fact but that's another thing that
could be an opinion because you and i
are on a computer right now invented by
this guy named steve wozniak
take a look at computers they were
developed for
the risky creative hard
work was done for decades
either in research universities
they almost used the entire city's
electricity
they have to have massive towers to have
a computer because
in order to allow entrepreneurs lots of
electricity
which is coming from public funding
overwhelmingly
so yes if you look back at it at all
most of it just
the creative hard general work is just
done through public engagement
now you take a look at computers again
in 1977
after about 30 years of development of
computers mostly in the public
sector uh steve jobs was
able to make a personal computer that
you could sell on the market
apple computer what i'm using uh and
then
the marketing the development and so on
was mostly
transferred to the private sector now
it's more complex than this so ibm
for example after learning
how to switch from punch cords
to modern computers
they learned that mostly in labs like
the one i was working at at mit
but they did advance to that point then
they were
able to develop their own computer in
the early 60s
stretch computer fastest mode around but
nobody could buy it
was way too expensive so it went to the
public sector
it was bought by los alamos
and then it was able to develop further
and so it continued same with the
internet
which was being developed right where it
was in fact in the late 50s early 60s
public funding after about 30 years
1995 or so it was
essentially handed over to private power
uh private largely privatized
that's the way a lot of the economy
develops goes way back
to the early 19th century 19th century
the main development in the country was
railroads
that was the huge economic development
they were much too complicated
and extensive for private capital to
deal with them
so it was handed over to the army corps
of engineers
the mass production
it's called the american way of
manufacturing which
astonished the world late 19th century
uh quality controlled uh
replaceable parts taylorism and
industry all of this which made things
much more efficient
it was mostly developed in government
armors
and handed over picked up and used by
private capital
now i'm drawing the lines too sharply
you look at the
whole thing complicated story there's
all kinds of interaction
but this is a large part of economic
history
all the way through that's why we always
have state
capitals yeah along with protection
of the masters from market ravages they
don't want to face them
the reason we have huge financial
institutions
is because the government insures them
and allows i don't disagree with that
that's the part where crony capitalism
i'm not with that when the eight
the big banks got bailed out and they
got the checks in away by barack obama
or bush or
folks back in the day when reagan bailed
out i'm not the one that's sitting here
saying let's bail some of these
companies out because
in my opinion uh professor i don't think
monopoly exists without the help of the
government
i don't think i'm an operator quite the
opposite as soon as you start
deregulating
it moves towards monopolization with
we've
seen it we've seen it that's the result
that's the result
of handing things over to the market
that's the result of politicians being
for sale
because their campaigns they need money
to raise campaigns so i can go buy them
because they're for sale
and they help me create a monopoly
because i got a couple people in my
pocket that's that's been going on for a
while
there's a reason why a lot of these
bigger companies start off in different
cities as headquarters as they get
bigger
they put an office right in dc because i
got to go control some of the regulation
and laws to not allow the other smaller
guy to compete
with me long term you're looking at
footnotes
the main thing is that when you begin to
deregulate
and hand things over to the market
there's a tendency
strong tendency to move towards
monopolization
as the bigger fish eat the littler fish
have
more power i can't under price i i
we're not we're not off page here
because i've been on calls before where
the ftc
we were doing business with this one
company all of a sudden i get a call
from ftc they won't have a call with us
great so we want your entire team to be
on the call okay
what's this column out to go back to
capitalism
that's why the owners and managers of
the world
those who adam smith called the masters
of the universe
the owners of concentrated capital
that's why they have
always called on the state to rescue
them from disaster
so going back to the original point all
over the world
we have one or another variety of state
capitalism
but why do why do politicians fall for
that though why do politicians fall for
that politicians can say we're not
bailing you out why do they bail them
out
the politician doesn't have to say yes
we'll bail you out
no we're going to let the market decide
how you do why would they bail them out
sorry why would they want so you're
saying these these
masters of the universe that adam smith
talks about
they almost always go to the public to
bail them out but the public has the
right to say
no we're not going to bail you out why
do they keep saying yes because they
have very few choices
no if you're if you're if you're an
individual
right can you say i don't like the
monopoly
of the the
comcast and two or three what are you
going to do about it
well no i'm going to the the public is
to sit here
but to sit here and say everything is
the private's fault and everything good
that ever happened was because of the
public and the government not the
private
that's extremely naive to say that
because you're you're then painting the
picture of the public and all the
responsibility that they have to reject
these ideas by this
everybody's for sale all the politicians
are foreseeable
it's the opposite i'm the one who's
saying
the public can do a lot that's what i've
been saying all along i'm writing about
you ask me who i respect it's the people
on the ground who are doing things
because they have the options
so what do you think so what do you
think about the guy that worked at ibm
and he was making
30 bucks an hour and he works there and
he's one of the public he's one of the
smaller guys and he leaves
after making eighty two thousand dollars
he doesn't like the way ibm does
something goes and starts his own
company he becomes a billionaire
he went from being the public to being
the top one percent of one percent of
america is he now a bad person
i have no i am not talking about the
choices that individuals make
these are the footnotes if you want to
be totally naive about the scituate
system
take a look at the footnotes if you want
to pay attention to the things that
matter
take a look at the major institutional
factors
okay we have a high concentration
of economic power as enormous influence
over the state
we have institutions based on a
conception
that classical liberals would have
despised
namely subordinating yourself to a
master
in most of your waking life those are
the
fundamental principles on which the
economy is based people have choices
they have options let's be concrete
about it
so when reagan came in and reagan and
thatcher
and launched the neoliberal revolution
which uh
transferred power even more than
normally
to the hands of unaccountable private
power
the first thing they did was to smash
unions
for very good reasons unions are one of
the ways
in which people can get together to
defend themselves from the onslaught of
private power
so if you're going to move toward if you
want to move towards a world
where power is in the hands even more
than usually
of unaccountable private power you want
to eliminate this defense
and there's been a continued onslaught
against the possibilities for
workers to organize and defend
themselves ever since then
it's a large part and so yes these are
the concrete things that happen in the
world
okay i don't care about what some guy in
ibm decides to do with his life
that's for him to decide is that good is
it good to have those
is it good to highlight those stories
where somebody
who was a low-wage 15 an hour guy 30
an hour person went and changed his life
and became wealthy and his dreams became
a reality and created 20 000 jobs
should we recognize that and turn them
into heroes in america
should we recognize it say steve jobs
you know steve jobs did a good job or
bill gates
of taking what had been created
in the mostly in the public sector by
lots of people whose
names you wouldn't even know unless you
haven't been working there for decades
they took all this and they turned it
into something marketable
which produced a lot of profit for
themselves and some jobs on the side
some jobs on the side you just say some
jobs on the side like maybe they created
seven jobs
apple employs a lot of people microsoft
employs a lot of walmart
employs two and a half million people
it's not some jobs that's private that's
not necessarily the government
right making use of what was produced
by the general public okay that's
correct
there are within the state capital so
what do we do so if that's the case what
do we do so i guess my question
for you would be and the only reason i'm
interrupting you because you told me we
started off with technical difficulties
i thought we had more time but you gave
me a limited time so i want to maximize
the time that we have together
so so if that's the case so what is a
system so it seems like it's a sin
for me to employ somebody in your eyes
like if i
employ anybody and pay them a salary
it's a sin so what's my alternative what
should i do to be holy
where i'm not taking advantage in your
eyes where i'm not taking advantage of
somebody else because in your eyes
if the private if the private market
hires and gives somebody a job
they're like they owned a person but if
the government does it
they're being very virtuous not the
government you're
eliminating the fact that it's the
people
who are doing it through the mechanism
of the government
it's the taxpayer who developed
computers the internet your iphone
so what do we do though so walk me
through it so one of the criticism
what do we do yeah exactly what john
stuart mill
talked about what abraham lincoln talked
about
what all classical liberals talked about
before it was destroyed
handed over the people who created it
should manage
and control it the management and
decisions and control should be enhanced
of the participants
you should change autocratic
tyrannical structures to democratic
participatory ones okay how do you have
you ever ran a company no have you ever
ran a company
have i ever run a country company okay
i've also never created relativity
theory no but if you've never
but if you've never ran a company what i
mean by that is the following so i'm
i bring people smarter than you like
yourself to be challenged i like being
challenged right but
on the company side to say have the
people who created it
run it the people who created it don't
run it
they turn over they turn it over to
managers who run it
they may make some contribution or they
may just
go somewhere and live off the
accumulated capital
but the fact is the matter and the
question is of the people who manage it
should they be appointed by a tyrannical
authority
which is unaccountable or should they be
chosen by participation of the
actual the people who actually take part
in and
run the place should they be able to
participate and control it decide how to
manage and run it that can be done
extremely successfully
very very sick where have you been oh
some of the most successful enterprises
in the world are run that way
name us give us five of them mondragon
for example
the huge conglomerate in the the huge
country
they're using the exception now you're
using the exception it's not it's not
most it's it's less than one percent of
one percent of companies
yeah that's right most of it is
government most of what happens is what
i described
the taxpayer can pays
for the develop for the risky hard
creative work particular individuals are
able to
exploit what has been done at the public
expense
turn themselves into tyrants who
run things sometimes for the benefit of
the population
that's called that's the form of state
capitalism that we have
and i think we should move towards a
kind of system in which
the classical liberal ideals are
realized and people are able to
democratically participate in deciding
how
to manage and run their lives including
the institutions in which they were
or professor would alderweireld i think
they ought to be tyranny's fine
say so it's not but that's what that's
what your interpretation is you use
words like
exploit you use words as tyrant tyrannic
tyrannical leaders you use
that's there's nothing but there is
there's a lot of people to sit there and
say you know we also have folks that
create these are no
many of these folks are noble human
beings who took time away from their
families at a time to create a job and
create a business
that led to creating jobs for other
people fifty percent of jobs in america
today are created by small business
owners these people are not millionaires
these are folks that maybe run a liquor
store maybe around a small market maybe
run a small
shop maybe do some real estate locally
and they hire five people that work for
them they make a hundred two hundred
thousand dollars a year
that's half of america's employed by
small business owners
are they tyrannical entrepreneurs and
businesses
so you you continue to take the
extremely naive
i think i use your word of talking about
the
individuals i haven't said a word and
criticism
about steve jobs or bill gates or any
somebody running a small store what the
public
created you said they use what the
public created they
and then they were able to create some
jobs is it
impossible for you to break out of this
looking at footnotes naively
at the individuals and refusing to look
at the institutions in which they
function
you take a look at the institutions
which so take a
take a business take microsoft
microsoft is pure a pure example
of absolute tyranny the decisions are
made at the top
they're handed down to the next level go
down to the bottom
at the very bottom you have the right to
rent yourself to them
that's what was abhorred not only by
classical liberals
but by thousands of years of tradition
we've
internalized it and i don't think we
should
i think these institutions should be run
democratically
by the people who participate in them
making use
of the contributions that the general
society the general public
has made over the years to create
the technology that is now being
appropriated
to use in these weights that's the issue
that's nothing to do with individuals
maybe the guy who runs it is the nicest
guy in the world
fine i'm talking about what the
institution does
so let's take jp morgan chase the
world's biggest bank
maybe the guy who writes it who runs it
is the absolute nicest guy in the world
he is institutionally constrained
to spend the money of jp morgan chase
to destroy the prospects for human life
on earth
that's if he doesn't do it he'll be
replaced by somebody else who will do it
that's the nature of the state
capitalist system
and if we're serious about the world
that's what we ought to be looking at
not whether this or that guy is a nice
person
noam last question for you before we
wrap up one of the this is uh for us to
wrap up the interview
a lot of people uh uh have asked i asked
a question on twitter and facebook about
gnome and you have thousands of fans who
showed up and oh my gosh you know
you know do he's challenged a way of
thinking on this challenge a way of
thinking
thinking of this but there were a few
that would like to see a debate between
you and thomas sowell would you oh would
you be
open to a debate between you and thomas
soule if there's any point to it
i've read some of his work it doesn't
look very interesting to me
but uh if i could find time and if he
could find time we could set it up
what if what if i coordinate it and i if
you do it i'll buy a thousand copies of
whatever book you want me to buy
and we'll give it away to the viewers i
think the viewers want to see the two of
you guys have a discourse i think i
think the audience and the people who
you care about the most would win at the
end of the day
if you think so i could put it on the
schedule but you know what the schedule
looks like
wonderful if you're open to it i think
that'd be great because i think this
will be a way to even make your
make a stronger argument on what your
beliefs are the audience will win your
folks who believe
in your philosophies will win if you
address it with him
not with me but somebody like thomas
soul who is a
you know a thinker like you as well it'd
be wonderful to see the clash of the two
ideas
well i've done that a number of times
and i don't find it very useful but i
could
i'm sure he feels the same way we could
try to put it in our schedule if you're
open to it i could get with this team
according to this will be wonderful that
you made the commitment
i'll be able to make that happen good
but don't remember it won't be till
september at least you know my schedule
you know i will have i will have i know
he's also extremely busy
but i will have the team get together
and we'll do our best to figure out a
time that works for everybody
you know how long it took to schedule
this i don't know
you don't well your manager does okay
right
yeah you can ask him probably took years
because these are
very hard to fit things in so lots of
things to do
i don't happen to find that of much
interest
i think the world would love the two of
you on the world
tiny fraction of the world i think the
world would love
we would learn we would get smarter if
you guys would do it the word the people
would win
but again professor thank you so much
for your time appreciate you wish you
nothing but the very best
thank you so number one if you do want
to see the debate between mr thomas soul
and professor noam chomsky go on twitter
my handle patrickbetdavid you've got
their handles here as well
share it on twitter get it out there and
see if people want to see that debate
take place
i think the world would benefit we're
talking about 90 plus years of life
experience to discuss
their own set of philosophies on economy
america whatever else may be i'm sure
you want to see it as bad as i want to
see it but what was your biggest
takeaway from sitting down
you know listen to my debate within my
conversation with a
man who worked at mit and taught for 60
plus years and has written
150 plus books and whether you agree
with
them or not there's a lot of things that
he makes you think and i'm so glad i did
this interview i was just thinking about
right now what are the videos to send
you to that
opposing idea of economically i don't
know why i only tend to
interview socialists or folks on the
left on the economist side but
i did an interview with laffer a couple
years ago but that's five years ago so i
would only
drive you to two interviews if you
enjoyed the interview today i think
you're gonna enjoy my sit down with
uh professor richard forbes co forbes
calls him
the number one socialist voice in
america if you've not seen this video
it's phenomenal
the other one is with a communist
slavoji jake if you've not seen this
he will definitely entertain you both of
them are great
uh again if you if you're crazy like me
and you enjoy topics like this
go check those two interviews out take
care everybody bye